[Musique]
c'est dans la fraîcheur des hauts que le
président du département cyrille
melchior a été accueilli par le maire de
la plaine des palmistes marc luc boyer
pour la signature du pacte de solidarité
territoriale un peu d'oxygène d'un lac
l'équipement la mise en valeur de notre
localité
il ya eu des actions préparées prévu
engagé et nous allons réaliser au fur et
à mesure dans les prochaines années qui
viennent c'est sur deux ans trois ans
droit on mais c'est parti pour que la
plaine connaissent encore ne marche en
avant plus plus conforme à ses attentes
et à ses besoins
le montant total dont bénéficiera la
commune est de 2,2 millions d'euros sur
la base de cette enveloppe la commune
engagera un programme d'investissement
important de 10 cette opération c'est
une commune rurale qui a besoin de la
solidarité départementale
nous avons ensemble ah bon tu es dépôt
de des politiques notamment pour les
plus démunis
l'action sociale en faveur des jeunes en
recherche d'insertion l'action sociale
en faveur des grands mode ce sont des
piliers donc de ce pst et puis tout ce
qui concerne l'aménagement autour de
l'eau et tout le reste
l'après midi le président s'est rendu à
l'étang salé où cette fois ci il a signé
le pacte de solidarité territoriale avec
jean claude lacouture maire de l'étang
salé surtout sur le volet social le
volet social on va bien que non
on va mettre une part important pour les
personnes âgées et je pense que le fait
de penser au plan seniors que vient de
mettre en place le plan départemental le
conseil départemental et bien nous nous
adhérons à ça donc quelques pas on met
le pied dedans
les jeunes qui suivent un parcours
d'insertion trouveront leur compte aussi
dans ce fameux permis de conduire
attention il s'agit pas le d'avoir un
permis pour aller battre carey comme on
dit et là il s'agit d'entrer dans un
parcours professionnel d'insertion ça
peut être un caces ça peut être
comment dire un permis poids lourd ça
peut être voyez un petit peu donc qui
débouche sur un emploi au rappel par
décision en date du 14 mars 2018 que le
conseil départemental a adopté la mise
en place d'un nouveau dispositif des
deux communes à travers le pacte de
solidarité territoriale pour la période
2018-2020 l'etang-salé boucle ainsi le
tour des communes je suis
particulièrement heureux bas de dia
qu'effectivement on arrive et j'arrive
au bout du chemin du bas quoi de
signature je suis heureux parce que
c'est franz était fondamental pour le
département de renouer ses liens avec
les communes je suis heureux parce que
je vois des maires et des élus
municipaux qui avaient envie de
travailler encore avec le département et
je suis heureux parce que c'est la
population qui va bénéficier de
l'accompagnement et du département et
des 24 communes ce dispositif traduit la
volonté de la collectivité de poursuivre
son effort en faveur des communes en
allouant montant global de 90 millions
d'euros sur trois ans
[Musique]